l'ancienne centrale de bellefontaine est
hors service depuis 2014
et même si ce n'était guère visibles de
l'extérieur les travaux de
déconstruction ont débuté presque
immédiatement avec l'objectif de libérer
entièrement les 8 hectares du site
aujourd'hui chacun peut apercevoir le
plus spectaculaire la découpe des trois
cheminées mais avant d'entreprendre le
chantier presque un an a été nécessaire
pour mettre le site en sécurité à
l'arrêt de l'exploitation d'une centrale
quand on est prêtes à la déconstruire il
ya une première phase de mise en
sécurité de la centrale donc c'est
surtout repérer tous les circuits
s'assurer qu'ils ont bien été mis en
tension est coupé physiquement des
complots physique au niveau des câbles
et au niveau des débats chez il fallait
tout les vidanges et et nettoyer tous
les circuits et toutes les tuyauteries
afin que l'on retrouve pas du reliquat
de combustible d'huile lors de la
déconstruction depuis 2015 les cuves
d'hydrocarbure des bâtiments et des
kilomètres de tuyaux ont été démantelés
tout est récupérable ou recyclables
ainsi 3200 tonnes de métaux ont déjà été
cisaillé puis évacués du site
nous avons fait place nette tout autour
des cheminées et voilà aujourd'hui les
cheminées qui sont en train d'être
démonté et tous les matériaux qui sont
déconstruits aussi bien embêtant que
métaux tous et il porte un déchet donc
ils sont suivis par le biais de
bordereaux de suivi de déchets donc ça
veut dire que nous avons le poids exact
et surtout la filière d'élimination
une vingtaine d'ouvriers plusieurs
entreprises travaillent sur le chantier
et ses métal d'hommes qui récupère les
métaux essentiellement de l'acier sur
ses cheminées autrefois haute de 104 m
les tronçons sont découpées au chalumeau
un travail très technique pour lequel
l'entreprise a dû former cinq cdd et cie
contrats d'insertion issu du nord
caraïbes
il ya de la demande
je rappelle qu'on a dans nos métiers
déjà dans la déconstruction mais dans
des bases navales aussi dans des cités
industrielles dans les distilleries
il ya vraiment de la demande et
aujourd'hui ce personnel qui était
qualifié et ils ces personnes qui sont
avec nous depuis des années des années
ben en fait pourront se vendre ailleurs
et l'objectif pour eux c'est ça
c'est cet immense grue de 300 tonnes qui
vient d'épouser les éléments au sol sur
le site 5500 tonnes d'acier reste à
découper et fondre pour une nouvelle vie
et cheminées auront disparu avant mai
prochain puis ce sera le tour des
moteurs de la centrale
caché dans ses bâtiments adjacents le
chantier de déconstruction prendra fin
vers 2024
l'espace sera ensuite dédié aux énergies
propres les deux tiers du site sont en a
fait aménager on centrales
photovoltaïques l'ancienne centrale de
bellefontaine est hors service depuis
et même si ce n'était guère visibles de
l'extérieur les travaux de
déconstruction ont débuté presque
immédiatement avec l'objectif de libérer
entièrement les 8 hectares du site
aujourd'hui chacun peut apercevoir le
plus spectaculaire la découpe des trois
cheminées mais avant d'entreprendre le
chantier presque un an a été nécessaire
pour mettre le site en sécurité à
l'arrêt de l'exploitation d'une centrale
quand on est prêtes à la déconstruire il
ya une première phase de mise en
sécurité de la centrale
donc c'est surtout repérer tous les
circuits s'assurer qu'ils ont bien été
mis en tension est coupé physiquement
dès qu'on perd physique au niveau des
câbles et au niveau des bâches et il
fallait tout les vidanges et et nettoyer
tous les circuits du tout les
tuyauteries afin qu'on ne retrouve pas
du reliquat de combustible et d'huile
lors de la déconstruction depuis 2015
les cuves d'hydrocarbure des bâtiments
et des kilomètres de tuyaux ont été
démantelés tout est récupérable ou
recyclables ainsi 3200 tonnes de métaux
ont déjà été cisaillé puis évacués du
site
nous avons fait place nette autour des
cheminées et voilà aujourd'hui les
cheminées qui sont en train d'être
démonté
tous les matériaux qui sont déconstruits
aussi bien b tant que commis tôt tous
hélas il porte un déchet donc ils sont
suivis par le biais de bordereaux de
suivi de déchets donc ça veut dire que
nous avons le droit exa et surtout la
filière d'élimination
une vingtaine d'ouvriers plusieurs
entreprises travaillent sur le chantier
et ses métal d'hommes qui récupère les
métaux essentiellement de l'acier sur
ses cheminées autrefois au 204 m les
tronçons sont découpées au chalumeau un
travail très technique pour lequel
l'entreprise a dû former cinq cdd et cie
contrats d'insertion issu du nord
caraïbes
il ya de la demande
je rappelle qu'on a dans nos métiers
déjà dans la déconstruction mais dans
des bases navales aussi il dans des
cités industrielles dans les
distilleries
il ya vraiment de la demande et
aujourd'hui ce personnel qui était
qualifié ils ces personnes qui sans
réponse depuis des hommes des années ben
en fait tout rond se vendre ailleurs et
l'objectif pour eux c'est ça c'est cet
immense grue de 300 tonnes qui vient
d'épouser les éléments au sol sur le
site 5500 tonnes d'acier reste à
découper et fondre pour une nouvelle vie
et cheminées auront disparu avant mai
prochain puis ce sera le tour des
moteurs de la centrale
caché dans ses bâtiments adjacents aux
chantiers de déconstruction prendra fin
vers 2024 n'est ce pas sera ensuite
dédié aux énergies propres les deux
tiers du site sont en a fait aménager en
centrales photovoltaïques